foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the pots
Moving and Storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where that is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
America Merry Christmas to you George
Campbell Ramsey personality host of the
podcast the fine print as my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five Merry Christmas
America we're glad you're here thanks
for hanging out with us Christ Is With
Us in Charleston South Carolina to start
this hour hi Krista how are you
hi George hi Dave how are you better
than we deserve what's up
so I am four months away from getting
near
me to the love of my life and that means
I am yes thank you thank you
um that means I'm going to be uh quote
unquote adopting his debt and I was
originally planning on uh using all of
my money that I've saved up for my house
um
to essentially pay off his debt when we
get married but
um I really don't know like how how to
like start back at square one once I've
wiped my mutual fund out and
um when I talk to my financial advisor
they suggested well this was years ago
they suggested that I use my Roth IRA to
save up for a house and now I'm kind of
torn because if I were to use my Roth
IRA I would lose like 250 000 by the
time I retire
so I'm very torn with what account I
should use and if we should go month to
month to pay off the debt or if we
should wipe my mutual fund pay off the
debt and then not touch the Roth
okay so how much is the total debt
um it's going to be about 20 000. and
then you have mutual funds outside of
retirement that you can cash out
correct how much and that's that's going
to be 21
000. perfect
sounds like a match made in heaven
now what I what I hear from you is
you're emotionally frustrated because
it's kicking you back to what you called
Square One
you're going I work so hard to save up
all this money and now I gotta throw it
at this debt that is a loser crystal
that's the problem
is that the heart behind it though is
the frustration
it's a simple math equation you clear
the debt but now you've got a thousand
dollars in the bank instead of 21 right
you have an emergency fund as well
I that is what I'm working on currently
the answer is no do you have one or yeah
not
I am so I have I have my thousand dollar
month
um I paid off all my debt last month and
so I'm debt free but now I'm working on
steps three and I should have that
probably in a month or two so but does
he have does he have any money
yeah how much money does he have
he probably has
four thousand okay four or five thousand
okay and you're married four months from
now correct
so fast forward four months from now
you're married we combined bank accounts
once we're married we pay off his debt
and by then you'll probably have most of
your emergency fund plus his cash and so
you'll already be a baby step four by
the time you guys are married then you
start saving for a house and no you do
not use your Roth IRA for house down
payment and any financial advisor that
tells you to do that needs their butt
fired
that's right so what's your what's your
what's your income and what's his income
um
to stop
soon right now I'm at about 85 000.
um
my
like my regular work nine to five is
about 55. what does he make what does he
make
75 000. okay so you make a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars married four
months from now you have no debt and you
have your emergency fund you ought to be
able to save very rapidly for a down
payment on a house and buy a house in
the fall
yeah
yeah oh what a blessing that is I mean
think about think about it you make a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars you
got no payments
you can't save twenty five or thirty
thousand dollars by fall
of course you can yeah
yeah of course you can don't go buy a
new car save up for a house
oh no no no definitely no yeah so if
you're married in March by October you
know you look six months further down
six months save up five grand each month
that's 30 grand right there so it's a
simple math equation we didn't give you
permission we just did some napkin math
to show you that it's possible if you do
it this way
yeah
um so our rent ends in
and
um I'm really stuck on that 20 down 15
year fixed well that would be nice to
have the 20 down but if you don't have
if you want a white Old Spring maybe you
got the 20 down the point is Krista you
got zero debt under what we're outlining
here as soon as you return from the
honeymoon you write checks and you've
got a fully funded emergency fund and
you make 150 000 a year rent something
very inexpensive and pile up a bunch of
cash by fall or by the next spring I
don't care it's not like you're going to
be homeless you're gonna get a home you
make 150 Grand you just got married good
Lord You're gonna be okay this is the
square one I'm doing good where you're
getting where you're getting all your
stresses you're having trouble making up
your mind and you're having trouble uh
releasing what was your plan as a single
and come instead developing a really
cool plan as a married couple because
you're still floating around back there
and before you were getting married now
you're getting married and that's a
whole new deal the bad news is you took
on twenty thousand dollars worth of debt
the great news is you brought in an
extra 75 000 worth of income to work on
this so it's gonna work out you're gonna
be in really good shape you're doing
good there's so much data coming out
Dave about married couples able being
able to build wealth so much faster than
singles even than cohabitating couples
7000 was the median net worth of a
single person 68 000 for married couples
and only 17 for cohabitating couples
there is power when you come together
and become one truly in your marriage
and your finances and so that's some
encouragement to our friend Krista out
there that you're about to get
catapulted George you look like a
millennial Millennial but you sound like
a boomer I'm such an old person deep
down Dave I know I live inside it's all
that 17 year old it's all that wisdom
and gosh coming deep out of the Soul
you're finally rubbing off on me
that's what it is I don't know you're
just shutting your age onto me and
you're becoming younger you got a pretty
good head of hair and rubbed off on you
yet so give it time 30 years of radio
later I'll be bald too uh well we got
really the headsets maybe it won't wear
the hole in your head that's what it was
sure blame the headsets that's what
caused it this is the Ramsay shot
[Music]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more verse
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today our question of the day
comes from our friends at blinds.com a
great American company they have a
satisfaction guarantee that's 100
percent and that means even if you screw
up which I have done this and you
mismeasure or you pick the wrong color
oh I definitely picked the wrong color
and they'll remake your window blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and new promos they run every
month always use the magic word to get
the best deal the promo code is Ramsey
today's question comes from Teresa in
Oklahoma she's asking the term leverage
has become a ubiquitous term I encounter
when discussing anything Financial in
almost any setting be it business or
personal the user drops leverage into
the conversation with a smug and
confident tone that makes one believe
that only a buffoon wouldn't use the
power of Leverage The implication is
that through some Modern and Smart
Financial Jujitsu one dollar gains the
power of 10 with zero downside whenever
I hear the term leverage I act dumb and
say something like by leverage do you
mean take on debt and then listen poker
face as the spectrum of responses unfold
I used to find it entertaining now it's
just kind of boring and sad I'm curious
if you have any thoughts on the current
use of the term leverage in the
financial sense I once saw this as sort
of a verbal curiosity and a fun game for
me but I now believe it's actually a
quite evil use of the word thanks for
all you do
well Teresa might be one of the most
well-spokenblinds.com questions we've
had just wonderful Pros there Teresa
well and she's on to something
um they're trying to say I am
sophisticated I am an aristocrat I use
debt the other one you'll hear thrown
around especially with the Tic Tac guys
is arbitrage oh yes Arbitrage it's
another it's another that sounds French
and fancy another code word for I'm
about to get myself in debt that's what
that means exactly well charcuterie is
just uh adult speak for Lunchables and
so don't always believe the big words
people just because if it's a ten dollar
word doesn't mean it's worth nothing
yeah she's onto something and and uh
typically what you find is that the
people in like she's talking about using
the word leverage or Arbitrage or
something in conversation actually heard
it on Tic Tac and they that makes them
think they're funny or that they are
know something or that they can throw
this around as if they you know as if
they're on top of something but it
literally does mean
debt that's exactly what it means but it
doesn't sound as cool when you say well
you should take on a whole bunch of debt
exactly and so but uh basically she's
she's really identified that the the
person that is speaking this in most
cases in most conversational cocktail
settings around the family dinner table
I'm talking about leverage generally
that's Billy Bob who can't find his butt
with both hands and so you know that's
uh so I mean she's onto something this
is just arrogance is what it is and it
is just simply taking on debt and it
isn't uh in that way it is you know
cloaking the fact that leverage has two
sides there's a great write-up by um uh
uh Warren Buffett on this and uh he
talks about him he has always has a big
paragraph or almost a page-long letter
at the front of his annual report I've
heard every year and it's always it's
always pithy and fun and uh right after
2008 he uh talks about this whole thing
of uh leverage yeah
has anyone had who has ever used
leverage discovered in 2008 any number
multiplied by zero will equal zero and
it's really it's really pithy it's like
a comeback for where the type of people
that Teresa is talking about here but
Teresa you're exactly right it is simply
debt and the idea that debt will lift
something that you can't lift by
yourself is leverage a fulcrum if you
remember your uh you know the Seesaw
right that's leverage right and so it's
a physics term in that sense but but
yeah it's um it's always thrown around
as if it doesn't have risk implications
and as if the person
uh doing it is so much smarter and
sophisticated than everyone who doesn't
use that term and so you're onto
something it's horse crap well and it
sounds so good on social media to the
younger Generations who are broke they
don't have money to invest into real
estate or the stock market and so the
idea of Leverage sounds so wonderful
that I don't even need to have money and
I can get all this real estate and have
airbnbs and be investing into single
stocks well it technically debt is
leverage it will lift things you can't
lift by yourself but it the thing that
is every is forever been left out of the
discussion is is the risk that it
entails so as you add this leverage you
at risk and the more leverage you add
the more you can lift and the more risk
you have the more volatile your life is
the more unstable everything is the more
likely you're about to hit the wall and
you know bust the car up like NASCAR
throw this throw the engine up into the
stands I mean it's like you're about to
go put and that's I mean we were taught
that and I was taught this in finance
class I was taught this in real estate
business and that's how I went broke was
I over leveraged meaning I got my butt
so far and dead I couldn't breathe
that's what that means and so
um you know and I don't have enough
liquidity uh there's another there's
another one you can throw around you
know I don't believe in having a lot of
liquidity which means you don't like
cash which means you're adding more risk
to your life it's that's an illiquid
investment it's like what are you buying
water I mean why can't we just discuss
this but you know we have to throw
around 42 dollar words to act like we're
not we're doing something and around
Ramsay we know what all that means we
don't do it we keep the cookies on a
shelf where everybody can reach them and
everybody understands that stupid is
stupid you don't need an MBA for this
nope we'll help you get there I got a
PhD in Dumb that's all you need to sign
me up open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Geo's with us
in Orlando hi Geo welcome to the Ramsey
Show
good afternoon how you doing great how
can we help
so I have a question I'm 23 years old
and I live with my parents and I'm and
I'm kind of on the fence if I should
move out or should I stay here with my
parents what do you make what's your
income
um I make 30 000 a year I'm just oh
actually I just started working with HP
one Aetna Medicare for about three
months now so it'll be 30 000 a year
um I have no nothing in my savings
nothing in my bank account I'm starting
from fresh
hp1
you say are you selling insurance
no sir um basically a CSR agent so
um
um in enrolling um prospects okay all
right
uh
well I mean Orlando at thirty thousand
dollars you I want you to get out as
soon as you can get out for your sake
because you will have a higher quality
life your development uh into adulthood
emotionally will be faster when you pay
your own light bill and you clean your
own laundry and you buy your own eggs
for the refrigerator right and but
thirty thousand is pretty tight so I
might hang a couple I mean let's let's
develop a plan that by may you move out
or something like that and during that
time let's try to get your income up and
during that time let's see what uh what
we can do to to you know to make sure
that when you move out you may be with a
roommate you create a budget situation
where you can afford the apartment or
afford the little house or whatever that
you're renting but um uh but in general
the faster you can move out of the house
in your early 20s the better it's going
to be for you 10 years from now
I'll give you some homework to do here
start to research the areas around you
the apartments what is out there what's
the price and I would definitely get
roommates I had roommates just about up
until I was married so unless you're
making crazy money and you want to get
your own place and it makes sense where
it's not more than a quarter of your
take-home pay for example then you need
to get a roommate and uh you might need
to get that income up beforehand you
might need to have some money in the
bank for initial deposits with wherever
you're renting and so you have a little
bit of groundwork to do but you're close
man
right right exactly and um I I have been
doing some research and I see a great
apartment around this area uh it's for
about 900 bucks one bedroom and 1200 for
a two bedroom there you go thinking of
so I was thinking about
um getting the one bedroom myself but I
was speaking to my brother about getting
us the two bedroom
um but I'm kind of on the sense of
living on my own because I've been
living with him for so long so I just
want to be on my own right now but I
don't have a vehicle so should I
purchase a vehicle first yes you need to
buy a vehicle you need to pay cash for
it that's A1 absolutely and that'll get
you in a position to do that
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
everything
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
George Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host today co-host he is the host of
the podcast on the Ramsay networks
called the fine print you can be sure
and check him out there
so one of our favorite things to do is
debt free screams one of our super
favorite things to do is get free
screams on the debt free stage live here
in the Ramsey
Lobby and our most favorite thing is
when it's one of our team members doing
their debt free scream on the Ramsay
stage here in the lobby Dalton and uh
Ashley or with us Dalton is a software
engineer with us so welcome guys
congratulations thank you hey thank you
now we have to get this out of the way
you have um
you have the world's best possible
mustache for those of you watching on
YouTube and that's actually real that's
High Praise too and
um and
uh so your co-workers who apparently
adore you enough to make unbelievable
fun of you they there are 60 of them
standing around with fake mustaches on
to match up man and woman I might ask
yeah and somebody and I'm just saying
some of you women that's disturbing
it's just I was like what is going on in
my Lobby
it's uncomfortable to say the least yeah
it's a little awkward so we're just
going to put that aside and now we're
going to deal with your success thank
God all right so
all right how long you been with us uh
just over three years okay and how much
debt have you guys paid off 120 and how
long did this take 35 months oh about
the time you got here yeah all right and
so Ashley welcome good to have you I'm
not going to ask your incomes because we
don't do that for the team members since
all these mustaches I mean team members
are standing around uh but wow what kind
of debt was 120 000. primarily student
loans and a little medical bill okay all
right cool so uh did you just start this
because you came to work here or tell us
the story yeah that uh
kind of leading up to this I had kind of
grew up a Ramsay kid I guess you could
say uh my dad who's sitting right here
him and my mom uh were working their
baby step plan so growing up as a kid I
remember riding in the car listening to
your show wondering why are they
listening to this crazy guy named Dave
what's this Finance stuff they're doing
and then fast forward to us getting
married my dad said hey I'm gonna give
you a wedding gift but the conditions of
getting that gift is you have to go
through FPU so go Dad so we went through
FPU in 2018 uh wrap that up and then we
kind of hit this Crossroads in our
journey where we were thinking you know
do we stay where we were at or do we
maybe make a leap of faith
um and go work for Dave and I mean here
we are now like it's it's just kind of
hitting me right now I'm like holy cow
this is actually happening yeah three
years you've been here in three years
you've been working on this how long
have you been married three years five
years five years you said okay so where
did you move from Louisville Kentucky
okay all right so you your Dad gives you
FPU you you abandon your family and come
to the come to work for the cult and uh
yeah and move to the South further south
than Louisville Kentucky and uh then you
guys just turn it on so actually uh you
it sounds like you kind of got sucked
into all of this
yeah I didn't actually know much about
you or financial peace and in fact I was
a little hesitant when he brought that
to the table when we were first married
um I just had an assumption that that's
not something that we can do
that it's not possible for someone like
us
um making not making you know six
figures all of these things
um and he just encouraged me to try
so like let's just see what happens and
I think by lesson two which was really
overwhelming and I remember us sitting
at the kitchen table me crying because I
was so overwhelmed with our financial
situation
thinking what could it hurt to at least
try and by lesson three four I was sold
and I was ready to do this and a lot of
it was because of him and his
encouragement
way to go Dalton well done man good work
she's being a little nice I think
it sounded like he's making you look
like an ace right now I think she gets
big wife points today yeah well done so
tell us tell us about the journey what
was the process like to actually do this
stuff and go all right well you got to
find a bunch of money to throw this debt
immediately yeah that's a great question
so thinking of primarily our debt being
student loans and just encouraging
people out there
um to hear just a crazy situation at one
point our minimum payments for student
loans were going to be almost three
grand a month because Sally May can do
whatever the heck she wants she's a
nasty old one oh she's terrible
um so we were staring at that number
before we had made the move here
um and we were terrified we didn't know
like God how are you going to do this
what's this going to take so we just
took small steps let's try and refinance
some of those loans which we did
um let's maybe put some of these on
deferment just so we can kind of start
treading water to get an idea of where
we were at kind of get bearings and then
we made the move here and once we both
knew our incomes were going to be steady
Ashley was a trooper and found random
odd jobs but once she got consistent
work it was it was game on and so we
started thinking okay maybe we'll throw
an extra thousand this month maybe we'll
throw an extra 2 000 and just kept going
to where we were making like serious wax
at this massive tree we're trying to
knock down and it's finally down God
gets all the glory for that because we
literally
we were those people that were like that
can't be us there's no way this is going
to happen and here we are now and so
encouraging people out there like we
know that feeling that you had uh
starting this journey or being in the
midst of it
um it's all worth it and you can do it
and I gotta say we played a small part
the camel family Whitney and I played a
very small part in your debt-free
journey would you tell the people what
happened there yes so
this is very fun so Ashley very much
lover of French bulldogs oh no uh we
knew we knew in the midst of our journey
we were not going to be able to buy a
dog that expensive because it costs more
than a car yeah literally yes uh it was
definitely worth more than my car at the
time uh so we
um we just started planting seeds around
here and George and I got connected and
he was like hey would you guys ever want
to like dog sit sometime and sure enough
we've done that a handful of times for
George and Whitney so call that a side
hustle and maybe delayed gratification
because we didn't own the dog dog but we
got the puppy love too which was that's
man that is the best end of that deal
for sure and you got yeah you got paid
and you got to give them back yeah yep
so Joseph
I love it well I've got to watch her
journey and it's been inspiring for for
me and for so many other team members uh
to show that hey if you actually do this
stuff it works and we love to live out
the things that we teach and you guys
are such great shining examples of that
we're so proud of you it's got the walk
the talk t-shirt on about two years ago
we started taking the making sure the
whole company everybody working here is
not Hypocrites right like we're telling
everybody we do this stuff you guys need
to be doing it and so walk the talk
became a whole company-wide movement to
make sure everybody went through
Financial Peace University everybody was
walking the talk and doing the stuff we
teach and that kind of a thing so that
we're not walking around you know again
hypocritical all in our own Community
here that would be horrible and so you
that was perfect timing for you guys
because you were right in the thick of
it yeah
yeah very cool very cool all right and
so there's one other thing we got to
work in here right quick there's the
believe sign over here so word is you're
like a big Ted lasso fan is that right
yeah I call that maybe why that's how I
have the mustache Ashley gets credit for
even saying like hey you should just
just try it she used my words against me
and was like just try to grow one and
see what happens and here we are now oh
there we go okay so oh that's where it
all comes from oh now I'm catching up I
thought it was more like a Top Gun thing
but Ted last one makes more sense for
you that makes sense yeah yeah that's
fair very very good guys hey of course
we've got the uh live and give bundle
for you that everyone gets that does a
debt free scream you've already got all
that stuff but you can give it away The
Total Money Makeover book The
Millionaire the baby steps millionaires
book and of course a one-year membership
to Financial Peace University way to go
you two we're proud of you yeah very
very well done all right it's Dalton and
Ashley software engineer here uh working
on their MC trusted team for three years
and uh oddly enough 35 months is the
exact time it took to pay off 120
000 count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that'll put pep in your step right there
man America is running on that right
there I'm telling you that adrenaline
very very well done guys and is all due
to French Bulldog sitting I can't take
all the credit who knew that was the
Breakthrough moment this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today you hear
a lot of myths and outright lies about
income taxes like all tax software is
the same no it's not or you're in good
hands with any expert who sets up shop
during tax season
you really don't even have to do
anything you don't even have to know
about taxes you can just decide you do
it's crazy there's no regulation on this
probably the worst is getting a big
refund every year is a good thing well
that's awful of course not it's time to
stop falling for these lies you're
smarter than this you can arm yourself
with the truth when you check out tax
resources on our website they're free
they're easy to follow and they'll
actually help you feel good about doing
your taxes this year or at least as good
as you can feel about it our free
resources walk you through what you need
to know about taxes you'll learn how to
get organized you'll learn the truth
about things like refunds and how to
stop giving drunk uncle Steve and I an
interest-free loan that's what a guy
called it yesterday drunk uncle Steve is
the IRS you don't want to loan Uncle Sam
or his brother drunk uncle Steve uh
money all year and then get it back
interest-free that's what a refund is
and you'll figure out how to choose the
right tax software or a Ramsay trusted
Pro who will help you do this so how do
you do all this we'll help you go to
ramseysolutions.com
tax there you'll see our free resources
and the tax services we trust that
Ramsey trusted ramseysolutions.com tax
Rachel is in Washington D.C hi Rachel
welcome to the Ramsay show oh thank you
it's it's very much an honor um I'll try
to keep it brief my husband is 72 and by
the way George I'm bringing a Lunchable
board with me on Christmas day I was
supposed to bring a charcuterie board
but I've learned the new names they'll
never know the difference
I thought that was great
um anyways my husband's 72 I just got
took his first rmd this year I'm 57. we
have two kids in the University right
now
um and here's my dilemma you were on a
call yesterday with a gal who thought
her her husband felt the cash was just a
mirage or you thought it was a mirage
and I'm kind of in that similar
situation that we were debt free eight
years ago and then we stupidly did the
dumb stupid thing we bought a beach
house in 2020 we have since paid off
more than half of it it was about 650
000 and we've about 390 left and I was
thinking should I just take our cash
which I've been holding on to
um and I can pay off
um another 300 that leave maybe about 50
000 in cash
um you know but it's making four percent
that's my main question because that gal
that called yesterday I think you were
adamant that they pay it off because
it's only making one percent fitting
enough no I wasn't paying off I wasn't
adamant because I was only making one
percent that just made it even worse
I gotcha but here's the thing a beach
house is a toy and if you can't pay cash
for a toy you shouldn't buy a toy
so pay it off
just pay it off ASAP
don't worry about though you've got
other money what is in your nest egg how
much is in your retirement accounts
um the retirement just total our total
net worth is
that okay so 390 000 bucks is nothing
but that includes real estate I'm sorry
Dave that's okay but 390 000 is still
nothing you got you got you have an
emergency fund in addition to the money
in the 300 000 Vanguard account the 350
um no I do not okay well you need you
need a good emergency fund if you want
to call that 50 000 like you did a few
minutes ago that's fine yeah let's do
that and so throw 300 at it now how
quick can we pay the 90 off do you have
any other cash laying around
um we we well we yes and no some you
know we have our five to Nines we get
cash full of flow the kids um that's
College we're not messing with that
we're not messing with retirement we're
not messing with college but do you have
any other just miscellaneous cash laying
around
or an investment account of some kind of
a little brokerage account yeah how much
is that that's small like 60. the rest
is all in IRAs and 401ks and things of
that nature what's your household income
um about 400 combined okay
uh I'll tell you what I would do and you
guys may not be up for this you may want
to do it a little slower than that is
um I would take the 60 and the 350 and I
would pay the house off today that's
going to leave you about 20 000 bucks
laying around but with a 400 000 income
you can rebuild an emergency fund of 50
in just a couple of months
and you free up the payment on that
vacation home as well which is only
going to catapult you guys even faster
into this process yeah right because the
rentals we only rented eight weeks out
of the year and even that rental income
is like about 45 okay so we'll be
getting that later in the year as well
you didn't buy this for a rental you
bought it because you want a beach house
thinking yes and no I looked at it
actually I looked at a date honestly as
a long-term like another form of oh it's
a long-term capital gain it'll do well
that way as an investment but you didn't
buy it for the rental income beach house
rental income is a pain in the butt and
it's usually it's 99 of the time
rationalization justification for buying
something I just wanted so yeah it's
just it's it's not it's not uh it just
drives you crazy because it's the place
where you stay and you've got renters in
most of the time it's just bad so yeah I
pay it off pay it offer or sell it but
pay it off and it's what I would do and
that'll leave you see
they'll leave you 20 000 bucks I was
right you have 20 000 bucks left over
and uh then you make 400 and so you put
another 20 000 in another 20 000 in and
you'll have 60 in three months or two
months something like that and you'll
have your emergency fund and uh then if
you're going to buy toys it's fine
you're worth five and a half million
dollars pay cash for them
um he has retirement Accounts at 72 that
you can access without any pain penalty
if you want to go buy another something
for three hundred thousand dollars
that's fine you can afford it but just
take the money out of the retirement
account and go do it but I'm not going
to take it out to pay it off in this
case you've got the money you're just
just kind of cleaning up sweeping the
dust out of the corners here well Dave
this is a question the heart of it is
when we get a lot especially now where
interest rates are up on savings
accounts and people go well Dave why
would I pay off my low interest debt
when I can make four percent on my
emergency fund why would I throw savings
and there's a principle underneath it of
when you just look at interest rates
versus freedom and sleeping better and
not having that monthly payment they're
not factoring those pieces of the
equation into it it's just well I can
make five percent here and my interest
is three percent on the debt why would I
do this what do you say because that's
not that's not the only equation that's
a very naive equation uh there's more to
the equation than that there's the uh
the stress and the weight that the debt
represents if it's not a lot of debt
it's not a lot of stress or way but it's
there the borrower is slave to the
lender there is risk involved that when
you don't have debt and if it's not a
lot of debt there's not a lot of risk
but this idea that you're just simply
comparing these two interest rates and
that that's the proper mathematical
analysis of this is very naive
because you've left out the the toll on
your relationship you've you know the
weird thing is
somebody worth five and a half million
dollars I'm not saying she would
necessarily do this personally but
here's an example okay
um
I do not have any of our uh second homes
that we rent
they're not owned by you
I own I own a couple of I own lake house
on another house other than what I live
in okay and I don't rent any of them
ever
you don't have to fool with it I don't
need to and here's what's weird five and
a half million dollar net worth they
don't have to rent that but the reason
they're doing is because they got dead
gun payment and they're trying to figure
out a way that this makes sense
mathematically it's easier to justify
when there's Revenue like this payment
is driving these decisions
and if you don't have any payments
Lakehouse can just sit there it's okay
it's it's a toy it's a small percentage
of my net worth hers is a small
percentage of her net worth and it can
just sit there it's a toy and I don't
have to rent it to somehow feel like I'm
not being wasteful or feel like because
the stinking debt starts driving you to
do stupid stuff you wouldn't do
otherwise like put renters in your very
nice beach house you know
um you don't need to and you know if you
need to it's because you got payments
because you did some kind of
mathematical thing and you left out the
fact then that you got to screw with all
this stuff and stuff gets torn up and
where is the cost on your time and on
your emotions where's the cost on a
piece of furniture or a family item that
you left in there and forgot to lock up
before the Airbnb dupers came in there
pour up something you know no thank you
no thank you all that means is you can't
afford it that's all that means and
there's more cost involved than a simple
naive formula of well interest rates oh
shut up
it's not about it it there's more to
this in life than that there's more
stress involved there's the physical
toll there's making bad decisions
because you're trying to justify
something mathematically it's all this
stuff involved now worth it this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth to work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships George
Campbell Ramsey personality host of the
fine print podcast on Ramsey networks is
my co-host today open phones here
America triple eight eight two five five
two two five Merry Christmas to you
Jessica is with us in Austin Texas hi
Jessica welcome to the Ramsay show hi
happy to be here good to have you how
can we help
okay I have a question
um we got into some credit card trouble
um we are now being offered to settle
for uh eight thousand dollars less or we
could pay it off
um with a 500 discount at 20
000 but both of those are gonna hurt our
credit and we're gonna want to be able
to buy a house pretty soon and I know
interest rates are going to matter
should we try to settle or should we
just go ahead and pay it off even though
they're both going to leave bad marks
so you're behind on the credit card
yeah it's it's a
in fact we're supposed to get a zero
percent interest rate and they didn't do
it and then they were going to back date
the interest but they've already
reported you as not paying the credit
card on time many many months
yeah so your credit is Already Gone Girl
yeah that's when you call me acting like
your Sterling credit and you're about to
mess it up you're already screwed
it's bad but I don't want to make it
worse I'm trying to rebuild it
I don't want you to rebuild it I want
you to quit borrowing money
but what about like a house you buy a
house the way George did no credit score
and you know that means it's going to
take longer because you have to get out
of debt completely no open trade Lines
no open credit lines and then six months
later 12 months later while you're
saving up your down payment that credit
score will eventually become
indeterminable and then you can use a
process called manual underwriting to
get that house the right way down the
line so you're not ready to buy a house
anyways so I wouldn't be worried about
that yeah you're twenty thousand dollars
in debt not paying your bills on time
you don't need to talk about buying a
house right now no we have a lot of
money though we just sold the house we
have 130 000 in the bank so we're about
to be able to pay off all of our debt we
have 30 000. so total debt is 30. you
have 130. and so what's your question
today should you do the settlement
should she take a discount on a credit
card when she has the money to pay it
off you should pay the entire bill that
you owe that's called integrity
well I understand that too but they're
also they charge an extra three thousand
dollars on top of what they were
supposed to do and I called them and I
told him I was like listen I said I
don't want to I don't want to
get it for Less I want to pay what we
owe but I also want y'all to take the
interest off like y'all said that you
are going to do this place which is I
have a recording that they said that
they were going to do so I'm sitting
here I'm saying I don't want to take a
okay so what is the interest dispute
about explain that they always have to
do a zero percent interest rate on a
charge before I did the charge and I
never did it and I would call and call
and call and call and tell them that you
know to how to fix and each time they're
like okay well we'll fix it and then
we're gonna send it up to corporate and
then we're gonna send it back up to
corporate and they're gonna have to do
they're gonna have to back back track it
yeah which credit card Discover discover
yeah you discovered they suck yeah it's
incredibly and so we've been struggling
with them and fighting with them on it
and this is the first time we've ever
been in kind of in trouble as far as not
paying and all your other bills yes all
the other people's have always been
current so you have ten thousand dollars
in debt that is not this what is that
um we have a Capital One credit card
it's everything else is current okay so
just pay it
and um I mean whatever you can come to
that is
ethical and moral that you really owe
and you can come to that amount pay it
and uh your credit though is already
dinged this one little thing discounting
this is not going to ding your credit
and keep you from getting a house
okay
what's your credit score now
and it's like 660. it's not great well
you're not
you're not you got you got other issues
then
how do you have a 660 if you've never
been late on anything but this one card
because it's this card that has been
dinged in the crap out of it no
do you want to see it I can email you
stuff or credit report the only thing
you've ever been laid on in your life is
that one card and you have a 660.
okay
not in my entire life but it was a seven
it was like a 750 before this credit
card hit
so I mean how long have you been arguing
with how long have you been late with
this card
six months we've been arguing back and
forth for the last six months wow why
even argue when you guys have the money
to pay for it they didn't at the time we
didn't we just now have the money
because you sold the house because we
sold a house and we couldn't pay it
because we couldn't get it current
because the interest rate was so high
and the minimum view was so high so we
couldn't get current but where are you
living now a rental
no um well we sold our house and my
family has a house that we're living in
it's just one of their properties that
they had how long can how long can you
live there
um
I mean I don't want to stay here for too
long but for at least another year we
could live here okay what I would do is
pay off everything get the disputed
amount or not figure it out and get it
in writing that the that this takes your
balance with discover because they will
screw you as you have found out they're
a horrible company and so you need to
pay it off as soon as possible
completely and get it zeroed out and
then you have no payments of any kind
showing on your credit bureau report and
six to 12 months later your 660 will be
zero
and then you do manual underwriting the
way George said that's your shortest
that's your best shortcut because at 660
you're not getting a mortgage like you
want you're going to get a subprime
and so your best angle is to drop to
zero rather than try to get your get
your number up the only way you're going
to get this number up is keep borrowing
more money and paying it back
and go back in credit card debt and run
up a bunch of crap just to play the FICO
game and I don't play the FICO game
that's what you talk about getting
screwed those are the people screwing
you so yeah what I would do is get a
number that is ethical and proper in
writing from discover this week write
the check write the check on the other
one close both accounts and make sure
there is nothing on your credit bureau
report that is open
that every single item is closed no
trade accounts no nothing nothing is
being reported as you paying payments
and your 660 will disappear in six to 12
months and then you'll be ready and just
stay in the family house until it
disappears that's what I would do that's
the simplest path and it's the short
it's actually the shortest path yeah and
as we've seen here you play with snakes
you get bit I mean trying to get the
credit card companies to play nice and
do what they said they were going to do
is a fruitless Endeavor and it's never
worth it and people always open it going
well it's a zero percent interest I'm
getting the rewards I'm getting the
points I'm getting the sky miles and it
always ends up calling this show going
Dave or twenty thousand dollars in
credit card debt I don't know how we got
here
I'll tell you how you got here you dealt
with snakes and then you wondered why
you got bit
so the simplest thing to do is just not
walk into the the old cage Dave yeah I
hope that you remember this experience
the rest of your life and the next time
someone runs up and you do at an airport
to have you sign up for a free t-shirt
for a credit card you smack them
and walk away giggling I hope that's
what I do you need to recommend you need
to remember this I don't know Dave's not
scared of assault charges at this point
I'm not really physically but I mean my
God verbally like not a chance
Southwestern not a chance this is the
Ramsey Show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and your money
so the premise on the Ramsey show is get
out of debt and stay out of debt
because that way you have control of
your life some stupid but bank or car
company doesn't have control of your
life
and you have control of the most
powerful wealth building tool
that you could possibly have and that's
your income
when you give all your income to a
stupid butt Bank you have no money
and you have couch payments and you have
cell phone payments and you have car
payments and you have Sallie Mae
payments and payments and payments and
payments and payments and you work your
butt off and you get to the end of your
life broke and you say gosh I hope the
government which is well known for its
ability to handle money will take care
of me this is not a plan America
instead we teach you to actually get out
of debt
quit worshiping at the altar of the
great FICO
and that means that it changes what you
use banks for
you know what I use banks for
checking account
that's it
got a debit card on it
got several of them several banks for
that matter a lot of money in Banks but
for running this business and for
running our
real estate properties and for running
our lives and so forth but that's
basically all A bank's good for and
guess what when you start using a bank
just for that you realize how bad Banks
really suck
that they're absolutely the most
horrendous industry when it comes to
customer service they treat you like
garbage they treat you like a name and
so we recommend small Community Banks
Regional banks at the most and or credit
unions we tell you to stay away from
these Behemoth Banks because they're
going to treat you like crap and they
don't care
if you work for Bank of America you
should get a good job
if you work for Wells Fargo you should
get a good job working for a good
company not the one you're working for
they're awful and here we go again like
the sixth time in five years or the
fifth time in six years Here We Go Again
George tell them what's happening this
is from Wells Fargo right now from NPR
here's the headline Wells Fargo to pay
3.7 billion dollar settling charges it
wrongfully seized homes and cars wow
it's a thousand Millions 3.7
000 million
that's got to be pretty bad so the cfpb
Consumer Financial Protection
accidentally do this once wow
cfpb can do that they just ordered them
to pay billions in fines for this and
that Wells Fargo agreed to it which
means I'm guilty which means they did it
gosh they would not have agreed to it if
they didn't do it wow you don't pay 3.7
billion just to keep the cfpb happy you
go to court
if you're right but they're wrong they
did it and the cfpb knocked them in the
head this is awesome so here's what
happened people had their cars
wrongfully repossessed by Wells Fargo
and the bank took actions that resulted
in borrowers wrongfully losing their
homes according to the order from the
cfpb other customers were wrongly and
improperly charged overdraft fees on
their checking accounts
yikes Wells Fargo's rinse and repeat
cycle of violating the law has harmed
millions
millions millions
more than one of American families the
CP cfpb director
said uh reho I don't know how you
pronounce that go ahead Chopra maybe
that sounds a Chopra or something yeah
wow that's pretty wild in some of the
terms of the order of Wells Fargo will
pay 2 billion to millions of customers
who were harmed and the bank will pay
1.7 billion dollar fine
this is wild
and uh it's it's weird that there's such
repeat offenders you'd think they'd
learned their lesson after having to pay
which tells you how much money they are
making off of you America if they've got
Just 4 billion laying around to pay
fines and they just move on with their
day
and they build big big buildings
at Wells Fargo don't you what's that
Tuesday
it's a drop in the bucket for these big
Banks just another day at the bank and
tomorrow you'll see their name on the
newest stadium in your town going how is
this possible
yeah because we're screwing everyone
over
with this kind of behavior
the bank framed of the settlement as a
way to move forward
and reform the company's Scandal ridden
past nothing says we're doing great and
not guilty like we will continue paying
billions of dollars to make ourselves
look good goodness gracious
okay
well if you bank with Wells Fargo now's
a good time to not bank with Wells Fargo
time to look for a new bank what was the
other one there was
it was Bank of America that actually
foreclosed on a house that had no debt
on it in Florida they did that so I
always said you know we've done research
and 100 of the foreclosures occur on a
home with a mortgage that's actually not
true there was that one time at Bank of
America foreclosed on a house that had
no mortgage on it in Florida and boy did
they get their butt suit off for that
one oh God but these guys are they're
they're they're like big Tech big big
fintech here is um you know if you're
Google if you're Apple you're larger
economically than most countries
so you're somewhat insulated if you're
Wells Fargo you're someone insulated
they had a thing that wasn't 24
000 employees you have to look that old
article up that's like four years ago uh
24
000 employees had falsely opened
accounts and the customers names if I
remember the story crack
so these are Bankers trying to hit their
quota and get their sales bonuses
because that's really all a banker is
now is a bad salesman
and in order to hit their Branch quotas
24
000 different employees had uh falsely
opened accounts in order I I may be a
little bit off on the year or whatever
but I'm not off on the idea the concept
happened that's one way to do it this is
that was also Wells Fargo that's part of
their Scandal written past
you guys
how do you survive as a like how do you
still have customers after all this and
people still go there and sign up for an
account today well knowing all this
there's a couple of ways to grow a
business one way you grow a business is
you do a great job serving
and you get bigger and bigger and bigger
and bigger
you do a great job at your restaurant
and uh somebody wants you to open
another one and somebody wants you to
open another one and uh your sub
sandwiches are good and so then later on
your Jimmy John's right and so you do a
good job which Jimmy John's does a good
job right so they're franchised so you
serve the customer and you get big to
scale because you just keep doing the
right thing a lot the other way you can
grow a business which is the way this
one was grown is you buy up all the
competitors you take all your profits
and keep buying all the competitors and
you take your stinky horrible systems
and integrate them into every Bank you
bought
and then you did it then and so what
you're doing now is screwing people with
scale and that's what these guys are
they're just um
guys if if it happened a couple of times
in a company the size of Wells Fargo
you would go well it's a huge company of
course they're going to have a couple of
Bad actors
this was Millions
of you that are customers
millions of customers were harmed
how do you do that and even stay open
well because you people keep going over
there and running your dead gun checking
account because you think the little
Stagecoach is in your favor
they got the old-timey little logo makes
you think about your old Tommy logo
Millions
Millions
we're not going to fool me with the
Oregon Trail those people died of
dysentery okay we know how that ended
George Don't officially old no one knows
what the organ Trail is um I'm trying to
teach the young folks out there Oregon
Trail I had to throw it out you must
have been four when that was out yeah
just about four yeah good memory
computers were new
oh well the good news is America you
have a choice with where you bank and I
know it's a hassle to go like switch a
checking account but if I mean staying
away from companies like this that treat
you like this it is worth an hour or two
of your time I don't I just don't grasp
why anyone still has an account at Wells
Fargo or Bank the only thing I can think
of is if you got a mortgage and it gets
sold to a different lender I'm talking
about your accounts your banking is
there yeah that doesn't make sense and
you know do better my car did not get
repoed I was not one of the millions wow
well it's because you own it because I
don't have anything to do with these
idiots it's one way to avoid it I also I
know what a large snake that bites looks
like and I Don't Go Near them I thought
that was the friendly snake Dave he was
smiling at me yikes
he's riding on stagecoach keep in mind
millions
millions of customers were harmed
don't miss that please don't miss that
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
guys if you have not subscribed to this
show on your podcast method whether it
be Spotify Apple or Google or whatever
do so if you've not left a review leave
us a five star review one Stars don't
help
mama said if you can't say nothing nice
don't say nothing at all so post your
five star reviews quickly we need those
it helps the algorithm actually it
causes people to learn about this show
and it doesn't cost you a thing and it's
a way you can spread the love and uh of
course you can share the show and if
you're YouTube and you're subscribing
you can hit the share link and all that
kind of stuff or if you're listening on
one of the 680 talk radio stations
Across America you just tell your friend
hey I listened to uh Dave and George
today and they were they were fun and
they were inspiring me to get away from
Wells Fargo and
um all that kind of stuff and hey
they're telling the station and the time
that you're listening so you can be sure
to get us in there So eventually starts
with a friend telling you it takes that
word of mouth and that at scale creates
a lot of impact so thank you to all of
you who've done that absolutely last
minute gifts don't have to be less
meaningful if you're still looking for
some last minute gifts we can help and
we won't tell anybody you did it at the
last minute instead of grabbing random
gift cards at the uh oh Walgreens
instead you could uh you could go get a
Building Wealth live
event ticket oh there you go just
download it right off your computer
there we're going to be in Nashville
January 12th Indianapolis February 16th
Austin Texas February 23rd Salt Lake
City Utah April 24th Anaheim California
May the second we're going to talk to
you not only about debt but how to
really build wealth in the middle of
this crazy inflation stagflation
screwed up world we live in right now
how are you going to make it in the
middle of this we will show you the
details on how to do that it's only 49
come out we'd love to have you it's
George and Rachel Cruz George Campbell
uh of course Dr John deloney and Ken
Coleman me and we're going to talk to
you and teach you this stuff so yeah
check out one of those dates pick it up
it's a great stocking stuffer
ramsesolutions.com events
ramseysolutions.com
events Jonathan is in Lexington Kentucky
hi Jonathan welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi guys I've heard about you all my life
day and I'm going to be the first person
to actually do it
Okay cool so everyone's talking about it
and you want to be about it
absolutely love it um I'm trying to be
as specific as possible and setting my
goals um I'm 25 years old single a
homeowner and I grab 45k home uh
take-home and I next year I have the
potential like a hundred and three
thousand uh next year take home I was
about six or seven dollars an hour to
increase your schedule within the next
five years
um there are six goals I want to have
done in that time uh it came that twelve
thousand dollar emergency fund start my
15 retirement
um I want a BBA in finance that'll cost
about 40K but I'm pretty sure I can get
that through work and I also want to be
in the 300 000 home paid off after
selling my current one and then somehow
find a wife between all of that debt
free
um I've been floating through life since
last seven years now and I'm concerned
I'm biting them off more than I can chew
well I love your drive first of all and
it sounds like you're trying to make up
for lost time and I want to just
encourage you to you could slow down
Focus your 25 not 75 you have a lot of
life ahead of you and all of those
things can and will happen but don't you
know try to do it all at once and so our
baby steps are designed to have focused
intensity one thing at a time and that
means having that thousand dollar
emergency fund then getting out of all
of your Consumer Debt then the fully
funded emergency fund and you said
you're already a homeowner
correct what's left on your mortgage
72 000. all right what other debt do you
have
a couple personal loans uh credit card
and I'll be visiting you on January 16th
and I'm going to do my prospectomy there
love it fun so Jonathan you said you
were
um
floating before and you're anything but
floating now you're dialed in focused
and intense now what was the change
um
well I had a couple relationships fell
through and depression didn't really
feel good about myself uh
I'm down like 36 pounds I started losing
weight and stuff and I don't know I'm
just snowball's going I guess
okay so the
the answer to the broken relationships
and the Depression was to start
controlling the controllables and so you
start taking care of your body
you're um
you've uh gotten some help or whatever
and have moved your way away from the
depression and now you're setting
yourself on goals that's awesome way to
go
thank you Dave sure proud of you that's
a good move
um it's um I mean that's 180 degrees you
you've turned this whole thing around
and um uh
that's uh a good thing and then you know
we don't want to ever put water on your
fire you're doing a great job
um the only thing that George is saying
that I would agree with is is that uh
what I've always found including our
business goals here at Ramsey uh
including product launches here
including
um building a a a building uh nothing
ever turns out exactly like you plan it
so just give yourself some emotional
margin that if it doesn't work exactly
like it did on paper then that doesn't
mean you lost and so you know if I set
my goal to make a million dollars and
I've never made a million dollars and I
don't hit my goal and I make 800.
oh darn you know I mean are you okay
then and so my point is the beauty of
goals is not necessarily the uh
mechanical legalistic achievement of the
exact goal in the exact time frame it's
that you start asking yourself what must
be true and you're asking yourself that
I've got to do this this and this in
order to get to that place and so you're
now on an intentional Journey rather
than aimlessly being bumped around this
life by everyone else and so the beauty
of the goals is that it puts you in the
direction and the journey and gives you
the energy to fight and push and scratch
and Claw towards it sometimes you come
out above the goal and sometimes you
come out below it but every time you've
moved in the right direction and so
that's just give yourself a little bit
of permission to almost make it or to
more than make it and still say I hit
the goal yeah I remember this
conversation I just had with James clear
on the entree leadership podcast it's
coming out soon and he was talking about
how we focus on the the results so much
but what really matters is our identity
and the habits we're forming and the
discipline that's created as we try to
get to that result and so it was a great
reminder for me as we all you know head
towards our goals this year and Jonathan
I want to walk alongside you
metaphorically and send you our brand
new Ramsey 2023 goal planner that Rachel
Cruz Dr John deloney and I worked on
that will help you set those goals stay
on track help keep you accountable but
uh we're pumped for you so hang on the
line Austin will pick up and we'll send
you one of those goal planners Merry
Christmas Jonathan we're proud of you
Justin's with us in Salt Lake City hi
Justin welcome to the Ramsay show
hey thanks for taking the call sure how
can we help
oh let me give you some background I
just graduated last week from college my
wife and I have a 12 month old son my
wife is a stay-at-home mom our household
income about 85 000 before tax
congratulations what's your degree in
construction management good for you are
you in that field
yes I am and a lot of the
the income has come because of how I've
worked through school is that the next
thing we've worked really hard to
graduate without student loans good um
and but that being said we do have a car
when we're trying to finish up right now
we're about 1500 left on it I just got a
signing bonus for five thousand good and
so that would leave us 800 on uh on that
loan but the rent that got thrown into
our plan is that our son has been having
some health issues
um and
we have a appointment next week with the
Primary Children's Hospital here to see
if they'll need a surgery in January
um add in another wrench I need to
finish registering today for our
insurance at my new job so it's a high
deductible plan ranging from fifteen
hundred dollars individual deductible up
to sixty four hundred dollar in
individual deductible with the max out
of pocket double the deductible gonna
cover it is going to cover your son
it will yeah
um we lose uh we're on cheap government
insurance right now what's the uh what's
the nature of your son's medical
condition
um some gastrointestinal issues and so
we don't know if he'll need the surgery
and so I guess my question right now is
should I pause this stuff too we're so
close
I'll pause it for six weeks
take care of your baby
okay thank you your baby's more
important and we're going to take care
of them you're a good man you're doing
good work just give yourself a little
time it's not long you're going to pay
it off very very soon
but just give yourself a little bit of
breathing room because you got a
one-year-old that's sick and you can't
breathe nobody can when they're in that
situation I can't breathe and it's not
even my baby this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Merry Christmas America this is the
Ramsey Show we're glad you're with us
George camel
is my co-host he is the host of the
podcast the fine print and uh
also my co-host today Ramsay personality
phone number eight eight two five five
two two five Gary is in Riverside
California hi Gary welcome to the Ramsay
show
Dave and George thanks for talking to me
and thank you for the advice in advance
my situation is my wife and I have
inherited a condominium here in Southern
California from my uncle he passed away
in August and has been sitting vacant
since then and we're trying to determine
whether we should keep it in rent it or
sell it and I can tell you whatever you
need to know about the condo and our
financial situation okay what's it worth
uh probably somewhere low side 500 High
630 that's based on there was one that
just sold that was a complete
Fixer-Upper with holes in the ceiling
and everything and it sold for 490. any
mortgage one there's no mortgage on it
no what's your net worth
our net worth since we've uh acquired
the condo is about 2.8 okay you're home
paid for
ours is paid for yes
baby step seven sir way to go well done
well I mean it's just matter whether you
want to be in the rental business or not
then
using the the sunk cost analysis that
you've talked about before and and quite
frankly if I had 600 000 sitting on my
table I don't know that I would buy it
uh but it seems that under the situation
with it being paid for uh it's in an
area where there aren't a lot of rentals
available so it should rent it will need
some work it was built in 72 and he's
done very little to it I mean it's even
still got popcorn ceilings in that we do
have some money that we could sink into
it my wife and I our goals were we had
begun saving for a vacation or second
home and so we've got money set aside
for that that we could then divert to
this if if we chose to to keep it
okay
uh it's just a matter of what you want
to own
uh do you want to scrape popcorn
ceilings and own this and have be a
landlord and put off the purchase of
your second home that was your dream
prior to this blessing or do you want to
just turn this into cash and accelerate
your dream on uh you know second
ownership either one's fine there's not
there's not a wrong answer there's not a
not a uh nothing in the stupid column
here
it's just a preference
what do you want to own what the thing
your sunk cost analysis is the right way
to look at it because you know you
weren't looking to be a landlord or you
would have already been one but it maybe
now is there's an opportunity in front
of you and you say well maybe I kind of
do want to try this and that's okay but
there's no one no one out there are I
we're not at Ramsey gonna say oh you
absolutely should do this as a landlord
or no you ought to sell it no either one
of these is fine with me I don't know
you yeah I mean there's no uh filter
there's no baby step for this a lot of
people just say you know what I this
wasn't part of the plan it's a blessing
to have but if we turn it into cash it
will accelerate some other goals that we
have but some people go this is really
sentimental I want to turn this into
something and have this be passed down
generationally and so that that can be
important thing so there's nothing
cinnamon nothing nothing special about
that so if I'm in your shoes again I'm
not you but I might turn this into cash
and accelerate some of the other dreams
that we had
yeah if we were to keep it is there any
thoughts on what is a wise amount to say
this is the cutoff of what we're willing
to pay to fix it up and make it rentable
or sellable
well you don't you want to get uh 1.25
out for every dollar you put in
and so if you spend 100 Grand on it it
needs to increase the value 100 and a
quarter
got it okay something like that or a
hundred and a half right you don't want
to I don't want you to spend a hundred
grand on it increasing the value 80 I'd
rather you just sold it right so um so
you may talk to your real estate agent
about that get your you know get to the
uh Ramsay trusted ELP in the area to
give you some advice on what to actually
do they may tell you to sell it exactly
as is
um rather than the the money you could
spend on whatever is not going to come
back out
um so
that's generally going to be my tendency
spend the minimum on it if you're going
to flip it and the same thing if you're
going to rent it because what happens to
beginning landlords is they try to make
a rental property a place they want to
live and you're not the you're not the
focus group
right so I mean honestly 500 000 condo
in California
is supposed to have popcorn ceilings
it's not going to be much
this is not that's it's not this is not
the expensive neighborhood expectations
are low no no it's not it's an older
neighborhood uh yeah so I mean that I
kind of expect that if you roll up in
that driveway right so I I don't know
that you've got to do that or you're not
moving in it so you're moving in it I'm
moving in it popcorn ceilings are going
away but that's a different we're not
the customer in this case and so what's
your real estate agents will know what
you got to do is look at that from a
management standpoint if you're going to
rent it or uh you know are you going to
flip it and what's happening in the
neighborhood are people going in there
and you know re-gentrifying these things
in a sense and really shining them up
and making them Yuppie I'm not Yuppie uh
uh it's gen Z friendly
um and uh
man what happened to the other I was
just thinking that I was like how old
are they now the yuppies must have gone
the same place the Hittites went are
they retired they moved down by
nolansville I don't know oh man down by
the river okay down by the river in a
van so yeah that's what I would do uh
spend the minimum on it to rent it or
the minimum amount to flip it whichever
decision you decide whichever direction
you decide to go so ask yourself 10
years from not today when our net worth
is eight million dollars uh and we own
this condo and it's worth a million
dollars or a million and a half ten
years from today what are we glad we did
this are we glad we had tennis for 10
years are we glad we invested in this
and does that feel right or does that
kind of make your like like your stomach
goes up in your throat then don't do it
right so but there's not a wrong answer
it's a blessing it's a wonderful thing
your uncle left you and
um hey
take take a little comfort and you're
the guy that actually did have a rich
uncle
wow it happens when we met the guy he we
met him he's here yeah we just talked to
him his name's Gary and he lives in
California he's the guy I I knew
somewhere out there there was a guy that
actually had a rich Uncle that's him so
prayer
uh George have you got a rich Uncle uh
not personally
well that would be you yeah personally
yeah I just didn't want to dog my uncles
I'm sure they're doing fine oh I just
don't think they're astronomically well
no one's leaving me in their will
if you did have a rich Uncle you're
probably not going to be the benefactor
that's what we're saying that's what I
was trying to say in a nice way the list
is long not after I get there yeah well
and you got yeah
I'm low on the totem pole that's why I'm
Building Wealth for myself I don't
expect it from any Rich uncles that's a
good that's a good reason right there
good motivation well we had someone call
it Dave you weren't around for this but
they called and they they were asking us
for advice and we gave it to them and
they said well I don't think I'm going
to do that because uh I got family
that's going to leave me a bunch of
money I want okay so you called the show
why
I said I'm good I don't need this I'm
about to inherit a lot of money and you
guys uh your advice is irrelevant so I
thought well thanks for wasting our time
as well as yours that was very nice
that's an attitude people have out there
it's an indication they should not have
been left in inheritance and we say I
just messed up there don't count the the
chickens before they hatch is that the
same that's the one because you never
know what's going to happen until that
person actually is deceased and you're
actually in the will you're rich Uncle
might I heard you're being an idiot on
the radio and took you out of the will
or he went oh I have to add him to the
will you could have triggered his memory
there Dave so thank you I forgot to do
that yeah
oh boy this is what happens around
Christmas time on this show I'm just
saying all right folks open phones here
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five this is where we teach you to
live on less than you make a concept
apparently Congress can't grasp
1.7 trillion thank you very much
what's that number
they just passed to keep the place open
because they were afraid the lights are
going to go off
wow and um yeah there's um there's a
little um okay yeah that'll do Merry
Christmas will do that'll do that'll do
donkey that'll do that puts us out of
the Ramsey Show in the books
[Music]
foreign
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage and Studios it's the
Ramsay show where dead is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships George
Campbell Ramsey personality host of the
Ramsay Networks podcast the fine print
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
Merry Christmas America open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Brandt is going to start us off
this hour Hi Brent welcome to the Ramsay
show
hey guys thanks for taking my call out
appreciate it and Merry Christmas to you
Merry Christmas how can we help
well uh my wife and I just kind of have
a kind of a quick question here
hopefully but I'll give you some numbers
um we're 32
and we're kind of on baby steps six-ish
uh we live in two places because we work
in two different places
um one of our homes in in our dates is
paid off and it's worth about 380k and
then the other house that we have is
worth about 950
000 and we owe about 540 on it
um and then we also own a commercial
building that my business operates out
of it's worth about 300 000 and we owe
170 000 on that
um our retirement account is at 260 000.
so the kicker here is that we have a
two-year-old and a four-month-old and my
wife makes about 220k a year and she'd
like to become a stay-at-home mom and I
don't know about 18 months or so but so
when she leaves her job uh we'll
probably sell one of our homes in one of
those places we haven't decided where
yet
um and then we'll probably go down to an
income of about 40
000 maybe 45 000 a year
um what
do you make now
yeah for like 45 000.
and a three hundred thousand dollar
commercial building
Yeah so basically I bootstrapped a
business from like the ground up and so
uh because I'm essentially not there
half of the year uh it's a it's that um
I don't pay myself a whole bunch of
money because I'm not there just to make
sure that I can keep employees kind of
operating while I'm away
so what are you doing when you're away
taking care of my kids so you're staying
at home half the year
yeah
she's in a different city
yeah so so we live together every time
in each different city so when she's
working here in Austin I'm here in
Austin but I'm taking care of the kids
when we go to Minnesota that's when I
work but then she stays at home and
takes care of the kids
what does she do
she's in Academia she's a professor
okay
so that that's kind of you so you know
kind of what those income levels look
like okay so we're going to combine
households and land in one place which
place are we going to land Austin or
Minnesota
we don't know that yet
yeah well um I mean I like your value
system and where you're headed because
the way you're living life now is kind
of cray-cray
um and uh so I I like you know the
direction you're moving with this but
um but I think your destination needs
some refinement
um meaning I don't know why she has to
go from 225 to zero
there's a lot of options in Academia
that uh she could make eat you know work
uh just a few hours a week and make 50
to 100K if we line this up properly and
um and you know we're not going to
accept your business which absolutely
sucks as our final destination
okay you you two are you two are high
capacity people you should your goal
should not be we're going to live on
forty five thousand dollars
okay I think you can land better than
that I still get the quality of life all
in one city and her being at home
largely with the kids if not completely
with the kids
um and and that's a good baby step in
between these two but just to suddenly
take a machete to this thing you've
built
is not a good plan
okay so I think you need a better plan
on where you're going to land and she
needs an adjusted plan on where she's
going to land and that's going to put
you guys well up over a hundred and
you've got a sustainable situation then
that's not as bizarre as you originally
outlined when you came on because dude I
mean you have to admit what you're
outlining is pretty bizarre
oh yeah it's wild yeah that's why we
called yeah what kind of business are
you running
so it's it's like a retail it's um it's
a retail business it does like we do
some
um
uh like training we do some like like
physical fitness training things like
that and then we have some products and
random things like that and I don't we I
don't foresee that being our full-time
business uh you know it's just like
right now if we had a fallback and
because her family is there and that's
where our families are up in Minnesota
we could operate yeah it's like we could
operate there for as long as we wanted
um I wouldn't land there out of
convenience what I want you to do is
have some intentionality about both of
your careers and your location
and go okay then that will tell you how
you can back into this and say over the
next 18 24 months whatever we can make
these six moves uh two of them on her
career two of them on your career two of
them on the real estate decisions and
then that will put us in this this other
position that is a sustainable life then
with a standard Rhythm to it
but um I mean I I don't blame you for
wanting to change the way that you guys
are living now it's kind of wild and
um it's been you know it's obviously run
its course it's time it's time for you
to do something different so
um but
but I think the uh the fact that this
season is over has led you all to just
this extreme thing of nothing
we're going from uh 100 miles an hour to
full stop and I I think you can go from
100 miles an hour down to 50 miles an
hour in between the two of you I income
wise and by the time you're located and
get the efficiency of being in one
location sell off a piece of real estate
open a business don't open a business
expand the one you've got take a
different career field I don't care
and part of this is getting rid of some
of this debt and so the commercial debt
the personal debt of the mortgage the
sooner you guys are completely debt free
and your personal life and your
professional life the easier it's going
to be to make these kinds of financial
decisions yeah yeah that's going to put
you in the right direction but the the
beautiful part about both of your
skill sets is they can be scaled up or
down they don't have to go zero or not
or 100 miles an hour
you don't have to be all or nothing and
so
um
higher ed is
like a lot of things is being impacted
by the digital world and is morphing and
so she's just got other choices that she
can look at now she teach a few classes
online doesn't have to be scale it down
yeah the amount of mentoring and uh
tutoring all kinds of different things I
don't know exactly what she's doing in
Academia but um there's a lot of there's
just a lot of options in that world
right now because they don't have a lot
of choices they're going to have to
provide options
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today if you've gone through
Financial Peace University chances are
it's because someone in your life lit a
fire in you Mom and Dad gave it to you
as a gift your pastor offered it at your
church a friend that wouldn't stop
talking about it so finally you took the
class you worked the baby steps now
everything's different you changed your
entire future well maybe this is the
time you light a fire under someone else
you can give someone you care about
Financial Peace University and share the
same hope that you discovered with money
and if you're a last minute Christmas
Shopper it's pretty easy to do this
uh it's not too late for Financial Peace
University we've got a totally digital
way to send it directly to your loved
ones so you're not stressed about
shipping this Christmas give the people
you care about a gift that actually
matters the gift is Hope
the gift is freedom to buy FPU as a gift
go to ramseysolutions.com
give FPU
ramsaysolutions.com give FPU Bonnie is
in Kansas City hi Bonnie welcome to the
Ramsay show
hi happy holidays Dave and George
um we are very new to the journey of
becoming debt free and learn about your
methods about five months ago through a
friend on Facebook
um they posted that they paid off their
home which was really awesome and I'm
very very happy to have come across your
debt-free program as I despise bills
like most people do we're one month away
from completing baby step two
um we have several rental properties
with one of them being a fourplex we're
at about 58 LTV and we're currently cash
flowing in all the properties and we
really want to keep them we want to
aggressively pay off their mortgages
with a gazelle intensity and we're so
serious in paying off these mortgages
that we've moved into one of the rentals
with the lowest expenses so the mortgage
is like 6.25 and my question Dave is
related to I actually have two questions
um related to baby step three is saving
seventy thousand dollars for emergencies
just for the properties too high or too
low is that a good Ballpark and my
second question is related to the step
six after we pay off the property that
we're currently living in
um which property should we attack
cool way to go Bonnie good job
very well done okay so the total debt on
the all the properties combined is what
the total debt
um well I would say annual or like this
no no the balance the payoff balance
on all of the mortgages is 1.7 million
okay on how many properties
uh it's nine units that are rentals okay
and you're living in one of them
that's correct okay all right cool
and uh what is your household income
we bring in uh take home with the
rentals is 26 000 without is about ten
thousand
that's your total household income
you're living off the monthly
so that's what we're bringing
that's what we're bringing with I mean
you don't have careers separate from the
rentals
oh yes we do it's ten thousand dollars a
month a month okay God I feel so much
better scared okay I was asking yeah I
was actually annual and you said ten
thousand dollars and twenty six okay
that makes a lot more sense good okay so
you so you make 150 a year and uh and
then you've got the rentals on top of
that okay so what I would tell you is
set up a household emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses to
operate your household that's nowhere
near 70 grand
that's going to be 15 or something like
that okay
um and then you're you're you should be
able if you haven't already to run
budgets on your rentals you have enough
rentals that you should see a pattern of
repairs
that out of nine I buy an air con I buy
a heat and air unit one a year or I buy
1.5 a year
um out of nine I spend X on this problem
this problem and that problem uh you
have a predictable repairs pattern on a
portfolio that size
and that should be built into your
budget on your rentals before you're
taking money out of the rentals you
should be setting aside money for that
predictable in other words retained
earnings or emergency fund whatever you
want to call it for your known repairs
that are in a pattern on that many
rentals so your rental portfolio
probably does need 50 to 70 grand in
liquid cash sitting around because
you're probably seeing a standard rhythm
of repairs does that make sense
yes okay so yeah you do want to build
that up uh but but as far as baby step
three goes that that that second part of
the discussion on the rentals is for the
rentals baby step three is for you
that's just 15 grand and then move on to
baby step four uh and four five four
five and six is putting money into
retirement five is kids college and six
is we start paying off all real estate
debt now the last question was what
order do I do this I would just run a
debt snowball on them and and it's not a
panic once you get out of baby step
three we move from intense to
intentional
and so I want you to systematically say
if we plow
all profits from the rentals and we live
on our incomes we plow all profits from
the rentals and X number of dollars from
our income into that snowball and you
just list your mortgages smallest to
largest
how long is it going to take us to clear
1.7 million my guess is five to seven
years
yeah we're estimating about seven to
seven years seven to ten years okay not
a bad guess then okay and uh the thing
that will happen is uh you know rents
will go up during that time they
generally do your income will go up
during that time generally does and
you're going to get more and more and
more focused as you go along you
generally do and so that's where I think
the seven is probably going to end up
being the number or six or something
like that unless you get a landfall of
some kind and then you might even end up
doing it faster and something that you
could do if you want to accelerate that
is choose the rental that gives you the
most pain in the in the rear end and
sell one or two of them if you want to
accelerate this thing and clean up the
debt faster so that's an option for you
as well yeah your least favorite one or
two
clean them out of the portfolio and use
that money to accelerate this process
and then when you are completely free
and you're just cash these things are
cash flow like a bandit then then you
can buy other properties with the cash
that they're throwing off and never be
in debt again that's what I've done
that makes sense yeah I just once I got
free then all of my property makes
enough money that I can buy more
property just with that money without
even having to look at my personal
income or my business income or anything
else that's where it really gets fun
yeah it really does get it really gets
it gets real fun less of a pain yeah
it's Monopoly then you know you're just
going around the board and collecting
your 200 at the turn right and move on
to the next deal and that's that starts
to be really cool so that but um but I I
would not tell you to be intense once
you get out of debt personally and have
your emergency fund in place personally
I would tell you to be intentional
yeah I mean you gotta you want to live
your life you still want to go on
vacations and so you may want to get a
primary residence that you actually
enjoy instead of living in this rental
property that you hate just because it
has the lowest payment so that would be
a goal as well to throw in there your
own personal life yeah but if you'll pay
a price for that period of time this
this next five to seven years and the
price is simply worked when we're faced
with a choice we're going to try to
choose debt free we're going to choose
debt free we're gonna choose debt free
and maybe like George said peel off one
of those two one or two of the rentals
that you like the least that you say hey
10 years from now I really don't want to
be owning this thing yeah well Dave some
of your most controversial advice is to
pay cash for investment property yeah
people go Dave that's insane you gotta
just leverage that why would you wait
and try to save up hundreds of thousands
of dollars what do you say to those
people uh foreign I've never been
foreclosed on since I went this route I
used to get foreclosed on the other way
wow I lost everything the other way
using Tic Tac plans I went broke you
wait you mean the 17 year old that told
me how to get rich quick from Real
Estate is not telling the truth
there's a 17 year old they're all over
the Internet oh yeah telling people
about real estate at least he looks like
it he can't grow facial hair yet so I'm
not sure
[Music]
she could be 22.
world what a time to be alive what a
world foreign
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Ty host of the Ramsey Network's fine
print podcast is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the debt
free stage Zachary and Cassandra are
with us hey guys how are you good it's
amazing how are you better than we
deserve welcome good to have you where
do you live
Chesapeake Virginia well welcome to
Nashville Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas how much debt have you all
paid off we've paid off 97
181 cool 11 months 11 months all right
and what was your range of income during
that year we started at 180 and then
finished at about 2 20. cool what do you
all do for a living we're both Engineers
ah of course you are
that's incredible okay so tell us about
this uh this journey what kind of debt
was this for you guys you were looking
to pay off I think it was a little
everything we uh we had student loans we
had car payments we had credit cards we
had outstanding tuition bills for grad
school we had uh taxes that we had to
pay
um little everything and you just
collected it slowly over time collecting
this American tradition yeah it turned
out to be the American Nightmare just
just creeped up on us wow how long you
guys been married four years yep four
years so what happened one year ago that
started you on this journey because you
got pretty intense here so four years
ago when we got married she wanted to do
the the Dave Ramsey plan and uh when she
mentioned that uh it must have Google
heard something and a reel popped up for
me and it was a caller that their
company was paying off their student
loans for them and minimum payments and
uh you said nope pay them all off and I
said wow that doesn't sound like a very
good plan I don't get it and uh so we
did nothing we just we worked and we we
lived and three years later we had we
had our first child and uh
we moved to Chesapeake and uh in the end
of 2021 my dad ended up getting sick
with covet and he wound up in the
hospital it was pretty pretty serious um
and he called me and you know he was he
couldn't really talk without getting
winded but he called me and he said hey
a couple years ago your mom loaned you
some money and you haven't paid her back
um you said you'd pay her back you need
to pay her back because she's too nice
to ask for it but if I go I know you're
never going to pay her back and I was
like wow
yikes that hurt so uh
you know that night I was putting our
son to bed and I looked at him I was
like wow what you know what what kind of
example am I sitting here
um for my son so the next day uh we're
at work
and and Cassie came into my office and I
I guess I was just sitting there with
bloodshot eyes and she's like hey you uh
you ready to do that Ramsay plan now
she was she was waiting silently for
three years wow
patiently waiting for the wake-up call
wait do you guys work at the same place
yes I work upstairs he works downstairs
so you can just bother him at any time
yeah she does she takes full advantage
of that and vice versa so baby comes
dad's in the hospital you get this
wake-up call and you're like I have just
been living la vida loca doing what I
want to do it's time to really start
taking care of my family yeah that's
exactly that's exactly what happened and
uh so that night we went home and we
watched the first two episodes of FPU
and uh we just we just went all in and
uh every time we saw a Tahoe on the road
after that we're like man you gotta you
gotta amputate the Tahoe that's it yeah
and when someone was lazy I'd be like
you're not being gazelle intense
wow I keep thinking of the quote when
the student is ready the teacher appears
and that's what it took for you guys it
took at least you Zachary being ready to
do this plan but when you were ready
goodness you guys are Engineers you went
there's a process here let's just follow
it because it works that was it yeah we
went all in how much did you owe your
mom it was just it was like it was like
two grand I'll show you it was knocked
out of course we just yeah
it was how's your dad he's he's
listening right now he made it and uh
yeah he's he made it out I think 11 days
or 12 days or something like that in the
hospital but he pulled through so good
there was a silver lining and everything
glad so that's good news well and he
busted your chops he still does yeah he
still does that's fun so very good all
right what advice do you have to
um
someone who says I'm ready to get out of
debt what are the keys to getting out of
debt wow so it's hard to limit it to
just a few things but we've learned that
there's certain friends that were like
spiritual energy Dementors they sucked
like all the you know life and happiness
out of us um competition it felt like
yeah having them as friends was
competition so I'm getting more involved
in our church our Friday nights looked a
bit different you know we take Isaiah to
the church and we're like this is our
fun happy place to be you'd be
celebrating and decorating the church
for a vacation bible school
um so surrounding yourself with godly
like-minded people was everything and
then giving each other Grace
man you know I was nine months pregnant
flipping furniture on the side and you
know we beat each other's throats and
we're like we need to give each other
Grace like we're both tired having two
kids a stressful working all the time a
stressful
um yeah just being together through that
moment
um and we have so many inside jokes now
and
I think we're better for it
um and lastly like
so I just had my second son here
um November 3rd and
thankfully since we are debt-free we
didn't have to worry about the horrible
hospital bill that I ended up rupturing
my uterine artery and staying in the
hospital for quite a bit of time and we
never had to worry about bills yeah wow
wow one less thing yeah yeah I remember
I was I was waiting for her you know
they ended up taking you to try to
figure out how to stop the bleeding and
I was sitting there you know just
waiting for something somebody to come
say something to me the last thing the
last thing I had to think about was
what's the bill gonna be because I
didn't care you know I was like we just
paid all this off in 11 months we've got
an emergency fund going and uh we'll uh
we'll do it again in 11 months if we
need to you know it was it was
peaceful good news is Insurance picked
up most of it I'm sure they did yeah and
it was it was it was perfect yeah good
good wow well it does it turns a crisis
into an inconvenience at least as far as
the financial part goes exactly I mean
you still got to physically heal and
still got to go through that process but
um it still scares the crud out of you
but uh but aside from all that
the the fear and the anxiety was not
Financial that's the point yeah so well
done y'all I'm proud of you good work
okay what advice do you have
for the guy who found some weird reel
that he didn't agree with on ours like
you did
some nuanced weird piece of advice and
he won't go along with this so I I when
I saw that reel
um of course you got to go into the
comments and that's where that's where
the magic happens the comments are
always you know that's where the truth
is and the comments were all uh they
were kind of hating on you that that was
a bad idea so so just take the comments
and and do the opposite and that's
that's actually advice whatever the
comment section about anything in life
whatever the commenters say in social
media or following an article whatever
they say do the opposite that is wisdom
right there I like that if yeah because
if you read the comments you understand
why some species kill their young oh my
gosh it's unbelief yeah yeah that's
where the hate happens for sure and you
got to listen to your wife in the first
year marriage and she says uh let's do
this Dave Ramsey thing just do it don't
don't wait on the floor we could add our
house paid off by now probably you know
but here we are you know we're on baby
step three cool we'll keep you you're
gonna be fine you're gonna be fine I'm
proud of you you've done a great job way
to go you persevered through you pushed
through very very impressive we've got
the live and give bundle for you the
baby steps Millionaire's number one
bestseller book that's the next chapter
in your story for sure the uh Total
Money Makeover book for you to give away
and stir somebody up stir up a Ruckus
and a Financial Peace University you can
give that away as well since you've been
through it uh one year membership to
that so very very well done and you
brought the kiddos what are their names
and ages so this is uh Theodore and he's
just two months old way to go Theodore
Here Comes Isaiah and she is he is about
to turn two in January so we uh we Road
tripped out here with 202.
that was an adventure in itself you're
brave well these little guys will never
know the stress of debt in their
household because of you you have
changed your family tree proud of you
very very well done I bet your dad's
proud too all right count it down
Zachary and Cassandra from Chesapeake
Virginia 97 000 paid off in 11 months
counted down let's hear a debt-free
scream three three two one we're dead
free
[Applause]
[Music]
oh man a debt-free baby smiling that's
what America needs right now amen and
amen this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
oh
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today Psalms 112 and 5
good will come to those who are generous
and lend freely who conduct their
affairs with Justice
Charles Eastman said children must are
must Early learn the beauty of
generosity they are taught to give what
they prize most that they may taste the
happiness of giving
beautifully good good stuff James is
with us James is in Houston Texas hi
James welcome to the Ramsay show
thanks for having me I appreciate you
all taking my call happy Holidays happy
holidays Merry Christmas how can we help
yes um I was calling to get some advice
for how I can
um give my uh family and my wife's the
kind of Life uh and lifestyle we want
um
it just seems like I've been hitting
some roadblocks uh I used to be a
teacher and I just I didn't have the
patience for it and I was really
stressed out and so I transitioned into
truck driving
and it's making a little bit more money
but it's harder on my wife because
her eventual dream is to be a
stay-at-home mom and it puts me out a
lot more and I'm not able to uh spend as
much time with them and
um
you know uh just help her out in any way
that I can
what's your question
How can I
my question is
what how am I able to
um
if we if we keep on hitting these
roadblocks of not being able to stick to
a budget and
um just
sorry I'm a little nervous that's okay
um we're having a hard time
um sticking to our budget we we paid off
our debt when babies have three so we're
trying to save up our emergency fund but
um
how how am I uh how how can we better
stick to our budget so that you know we
can get that emergency fund saved up I
can transition to a more home daily
uh position maybe start a side business
so that I'm able to let my wife work or
uh be a stay-at-home mom and still be
able to support my family
so the goal is she stays home and you
work locally and your income is more
than enough to provide for the family
yes yes sir that's correct is there a
certain number you think would do that
as far as income
well we we both used to teach so we made
a little over a hundred thousand
um a year but it doesn't seem like I can
really do that by myself unless I you
know
start up a side business and eventually
grow that to be more profitable
well I I think you can it may not happen
tomorrow but it sounds like you jumped
from teaching to trucking thinking it
was going to be some kind of Silver
Bullet but it wasn't
yes sir why are you not able to stick to
a budget
what give me an example of when the
budget breaks down
well um
sometimes
um
you know if
we're you know my wife is stressed with
things at the house and
um she needs to eat out or
um
yeah something how old are you guys
recently
I'm 30 years old how old is she my wife
is
she's 30 as well okay and how many
children do you have
one child what age
seven okay
all right um
I'm hearing some hints in here that the
responsibility for all of this is on you
that she's not taking any of the
responsibility for this
am I missing something
well I I am trying to be the head of my
household that's not what I said
it's not a matter of what's ahead of the
household is she is also the an adult
member of this household and has a
co-responsibility for living within a
budget and having it having to achieve
household goals
it sounds like all of these this goal
achievement is is on you and she's not
participating in carrying any of the
load
well
I don't
I don't know I just I feel like
um
no matter what I try and do I I just
can't seem to make it make it work
because it's just you
if I make it work do you mean make her
happy
yeah and you know get our emergency fund
and
be but you have you've worked through
the you said you've been working through
the baby steps but you keep falling off
the budget and the only and the
explanation of falling off the budget
was she got stressed and went out to eat
well and she wants to stay home
yeah she has a lot of things she wants
but I haven't heard where she's
contributing anything to this
conversation so here's the thing
families that
regardless of who's who's the head of
the household you can we can have all
kinds of theological or doctrinal
discussions about that if you want to
but families that win have that are
married have two adults that are
emotionally carrying the weight of the
decision-making towards a set of shared
goals
and I do not hear that here
bluntly I don't think that's what y'all
are doing I think you're running around
trying to do all of this on your back by
yourself and I appreciate you trying but
uh I got to tell you man if she's not
willing to say oh I want to be a
stay-at-home mom and so I'm willing to
be a home economist and I'm cooking from
scratch and we're going to coupon and
the kid's going to be in Consignment
clothes so we can get this crap moving
to get things happening then we'll you
know I'll carry that part of the weight
of this because that gets us to work
because we're both in agreement that one
of our goals is her to be a stay-at-home
mom I'm not disagreeing with the goal
I'm disagreeing with you trying to get
there by yourself
and you're towing two children along
that's what I'm hearing and I'm not
picking on her I'm just saying the way
that she the the highest probability of
you two achieving the goals that both of
you are laying out regardless of whether
they were her motivation or your
motivation but we've agreed they're now
our goals is for both of us to lean into
that and carry our share of the weight
which would sound like in her case as an
example I want to be a stay-at-home mom
so I'm willing to tutor from home
to bring in some income
after we make that move as a step as a
side step because you can make a lot of
money today tutoring
really good money while the kids taking
their afternoon nap
um so and then you you know you're
willing to go out there and bust it and
uh give up some nights at home to get to
get some over the road uh Trucking
income and to get your side gig going so
everybody's willing to pay a price live
like no one else so that later we get to
our goals but both of you have to be
willing to carry that James and both of
you and a key component of that is the
budget is not it's not it's not the
master of this situation and it's not
because Dave said to a budget but the
budget is the way you freaking get there
and part of this James I I sense some
shame that has been put on you from her
that you've created for yourself of gone
I'm not providing enough and I just want
you to see the true reality of the
situation is not that you're not a good
husband it's that the framing of this
conversation is a one-way Street and you
need both people contributing to this
and that means getting on a plan maybe
you have a dream date together setting
the vision saying this is where we're
headed I need you to contribute in all
these ways if we want to make this goal
happen and if she says no well then the
goal needs to change because you're both
going to be miserable and so we have to
do something about this and it can't all
fall on you yeah you're
but and you can get there this is a
doable like you said George this is a
doable thing it might take 36 months
but um the year that I quit doing real
estate and did Financial Peace
University launch
and went full time into this business
our income went in half and for the
following 30 months two and a half years
I worked 16 hour days six seven days a
week Sharon will tell you she felt like
a single mom during that time but the
part was we were in agreement on the
goal and the part she was carrying was
the weight of the household I was
carrying the weight of a startup
business and it got this thing off the
ground but there was a period of 30
months two and a half years it was very
very very tough in the early days in
order to get to our shared goals you
guys live like no one else that puts
this hour the Ramsey Show in the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]